it is an early hour of the evening when
the sounds of the city usually fall to a
few quiet echoes of the busy day
[Music]
avendy there is a crowd gathering in the
square
now some of them are picking up rocks
and sticks
why do you do it hameed all this
violence
what better way is there to deal with
the dishonesty and corruption in our
government
and the do-nothing officials who keep us
a backward country there has been
progress hamid if you would open your
eyes to it
by our own labors
and with american aid i don't see
anything good about the way things are
going in our land
and others are coming to agree with me
and we're going to do something about
what we don't like you'll see
ah
just you wait insane
let's go
these american troops are firing at the
iraqi city of mosul
this is the third time american troops
have tried to take the city
first from saddam
then from al qaeda in iraq
today from isis
when you see these battles as parts of a
larger war certain patterns emerge
this mad dog of the middle east has a
goal of a world muslim fundamentalist
revolution
we're here for more than just the price
of a gallon of gas
what we're doing
is going to chart the future of the
world for the next hundred years
the united states launched an attack
this morning
on groups affiliated with osama bin
laden
under the dictator
prisons like
abu
ghad were symbols of death and torture i
have determined that it is in our vital
national interest to send an additional
30 000 u.s troops to afghanistan
novel tactics win apparent victories
generals become heroes
and then things go awry
and new threats emerge
i would bomb the [ __ ] out of him
let me provide my own assessment of this
war
[Music]
we have not won it
we are not winning it
and simply trying harder is not likely
to produce a different outcome
[Music]
we've tried invade and occupied we've
tried nation building
counter insurgency
decapitation
anybody who imagines that there is a
neat and tidy military solution that can
be imposed by the united states is
deluded
yet that delusion continues to be at the
center of u.s policy in the region
going back to the carter administration
down to the present day
but we're keeping the oil remember that
i've always said that keep the oil
we want to keep the oil 45 million
dollars a month keep the oil
[Music]
okay
move out
[Music]
i grew up in indiana
both of my parents were world war ii
veterans
this is the 1950s middle of the country
conservative catholic household
patriotism was something that i imbibed
with my mother's milk
and patriotism really implied favorable
attitude toward the military and toward
military service
when i graduated from high school going
to the military academy at west point
was an attractive option and i took it
that was during the height really of the
vietnam war
students protest the government's
measures
my classmates and i knew that we were
going to pretty quickly be deployed to
the war zone
there was reluctance to think too deeply
about the war
and the war on the terror went on and so
did the political stability
your brain in neutral deploy do your
duty that's what i did
we should have been asking the question
does this war make sense
is this war winnable
and if it's not winnable why are we
there
[Music]
why do we persist
i've been asking these apparently
radical questions
about our role in the middle east
for 30 years
to little avail
[Music]
some say
that if we can put a man on the moon
we can do anything
but
can we solve our energy problem
in time
nearly half of our oil is now imported
we are exhausting our irreplaceable
energy resources
[Music]
[Applause]
think about it
at the end of the 1970s
americans believe the reserves of oil
and natural gas in north america were
being rapidly depleted
we face at all times the possibility of
an emergency shortage
a very severe reduction in supplies of
gasoline and diesel fuel for the
transportation of the people of america
highway drivers were limited to 10
gallons everybody knew the u.s
dependence upon foreign oil was destined
to
increase
the economic danger of foreign oil is
that the foreign suppliers can get
together and raise their prices or cut
us off for any reason they wish
that's exactly what happened
when the arab world reacted to america's
support of israel with the 1973 oil
embargo
and so the oil crisis induced something
like mass hysteria
in washington a house committee has
approved a standby gasoline rationing
plan
see if the keys are in the car all right
bob
they're here
[Music]
so
i'm cold
daddy
yep will we freeze in the dark
[Music]
we now have above a 70 percent favorable
rating in the polls
for our jobs so far but when we come out
with an energy policy we probably lose
about 10 or 15 percent of that
but i'm willing to give up some of my
own personal popularity to deal with the
impending crisis
that's going to come regardless
in future years as energy runs out
at the white house the mood is quiet
almost somber on this critical day in
the presidency of jimmy carter when he
speaks this evening the president is
expected to set forth a mostly
philosophical framework for solving the
nation's energy and economic problems
good evening
i want to talk to you right now
about a fundamental threat to american
democracy
energy
will be the immediate test of our
ability to unite this nation to give us
energy security
i am asking for the most massive
peacetime commitment of funds and
resources
in our nation's history
to develop america's own alternative
sources of fuel
from coal
from oil shale
from plant products for gasohol
from unconventional gas
from
the sun
the speech is enormously thoughtful
and in retrospect can be seen as
describing the path not taken
we're going to wean ourselves from our
ever increasing dependence on foreign
oil
and by doing that we will also become
the people that we should be
a virtuous people
with god's help
and for the sake of our nation
[Music]
it is time for us to join hands
[Music]
mr president
we've been told that the central thrust
of your new energy program will involve
sacrifice and voluntary conservation is
it likely that one of those sacrifices
is going to come in the form of a
largely increased federal gasoline tax
this was his proposal in the summer of
1979 and it was resoundingly rejected
he's trying to convince the american
people to trust him and these people
just don't want to hear what he's having
to say i don't think he said anything
the american people then and the
american people today
don't want to tighten their belts they
don't want to get by with less
they want more
[Music]
so often when the news comes in about
iran i remember new year's eve because
you and the president spent new year's
eve in iran and many reporters like
myself are with you
i wonder if you personally have talked
with them and what your view is of them
as at the shah in particular as a ruler
the shah
is communicating with opposition leaders
he is committed to a broader base for
the government he is working toward
democratic principles and social change
and
he has been embedded lately
and
we
obviously support him fully when we talk
about support what do we mean today post
vietnam by support for example if the
shard does fall it threatens our oil
supply it threatens israel's oil supply
it threatens saudi arabia it threatens
the whole persian gulf
[Music]
the revolution is on
khomeini is the symbol of honesty he is
the greatest man
that i have ever known
and i follow him because he just wants
iran for iranian people
the us bound up with the iranians hatred
of the shah
becomes the target of mob hatred in
october
iran is bordered in the north by the
soviet union and american monitoring
stations were deployed along the
frontier
despite the embassy takeover with
relations between the two countries
never worse than now iran's oil
pipelines to the u.s are still open for
how long is for the ayatollah to say
so the oil war began in 1980
as an immediate response to two events
one of those events was the iranian
revolution the overthrow of the shah
the second event was the soviet invasion
of afghanistan and in the summer of 79
carter realizes that he has to undertake
some
significant initiative
in order to persuade the american people
that he deserves a second term
this is a cbs news special report
here now from washington is leslie stahl
good evening on christmas day the soviet
union began an invasion of afghanistan
which took place on the 51st day of the
hostage siege in iran tonight a snowy
night in washington president carter
will address the nation
i come to you this evening to discuss
the extremely important and rapidly
changing circumstances in southwest asia
massive soviet military forces have
invaded
the small non-aligned sovereign nation
of afghanistan
this invasion
is an extremely serious threat to peace
because of the threat of further soviet
expansion
into neighboring countries in southwest
asia a soviet occupied afghanistan
threatens both iran
and pakistan
to possible control over much of the
world's oil supplies
there are soviet military advisers in
afghanistan actively supporting the
marxist government and the civil war
there
there is chaos in iran
soviet ships in the indian ocean
and a communist government in south
yemen a soviet foothold on the arabian
peninsula eyewitness news continues now
with jerry dunphy christine lund and the
eyewitness news team
from the desert to the sea to all of
southern california good evening here's
the latest at six in just a few moments
we're going to switch live to capitol
hill in washington where president jimmy
carter will present his annual state of
the union address to a joint session of
congress and a nationwide broadcast
audience mr speaker the president of the
united states
our white house correspondent sam
donaldson
is on the
at the capitol are we going to see
tonight the exposition of a new carter
doctrine
yes indeed frank uh we won't uh he won't
call it that but we will because uh in
effect the president will say to the
russians that uh any attempt on their
part to
influence the persian gulf states to
invade that territory will be met with
an american military response
an attempt by any outside force
to gain control of the persian gulf
region
will be regarded as an assault on the
vital interest of the united states of
america
and such an assault will be repelled by
any means necessary
including military force
prior to 1980 there was virtually no us
military presence anywhere in the
islamic world there were no significant
war plans there were no bases there were
no agreements for overflight rights we
weren't prepared to go fight in places
like the persian gulf for the first time
the united states is sending combat
troops 1800 marines to the persian gulf
area as a visible deterrent against any
soviet move to expand beyond afghanistan
new realities oil realities have changed
the national move from no more vietnam's
to
no more vietnam's
but
jimmy carter our least militant
president in memory triggered the wheels
of the national security bureaucracy
and they turned in a direction such that
the united states began to gear up for
war in that region
carter he didn't see what was going to
happen
but nonetheless he was the guy who put
things in motion
the american decision to send the
aircraft carrier constellation into the
indian ocean was a clear demonstration
of an important shift in policy
[Music]
a commitment to defend the arabian
peninsula and its oil
operation eagle claw was the first use
of american military power in anything
like a serious way after the
promulgation of the carter doctrine
eagle claw was the attempt to use u.s
forces to rescue the americans held
hostage in iran during the hostage
crisis
and it was a debacle it was a utter
complete and total failure amid frantic
moves to leave the americans splashed
jet fuel on their grounded craft they
fired into some of them three caught
fire and were totally destroyed two
survived
inside the belly of one helicopter that
remained intact guns bullets first aid
camouflage radio equipment it was the
supreme humiliation of the jimmy carter
administration in the aftermath of the
attempt we continue to hold the
government of iran responsible for the
safety and for the early release of the
american hostages who have been held so
long but in retrospect
i've come to believe
it's almost as if
god or the gods were whispering
don't persuade yourself that
american military power is going to fix
things
because it's not
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the saudi arabians share our purpose
their supplies of energy are crucial
to the well-being of people in many
nations
they produce their
own oil for world consumption
beyond the level
which perhaps would be best for them
this responsible and unselfish action
has saved
the entire economic structure of the
world from disruption
and has alleviated the fears that did
exist
when the price of oil was raised in
1973.
i think it's accurate to say that the
future of saudi arabia and the future of
the united states
are tied together very closely and in an
irrevocable way
[Music]
this program has been made possible by
grants from chemical bank
fleur a worldwide engineering
construction and natural resource
corporation and by the ford motor
company where quality is job one
[Music]
this is the gulf
called the persian gulf in the west here
it is the arabian gulf
kuwait qatar bahrain the united arab
emirates oman
countries known for their oil and for a
nervous proximity to the gunshot and
smoke of their neighbor's wars
beyond that countries almost totally
unknown to most of the public
in 1498 approximately the time that
columbus sailed to america the king of
portugal sent the famous portuguese
admiral albuquerque the mandate conquer
the gulf
he began a chapter of european
domination that changed the world of the
gulf the portuguese attacked the towns
on the coast and then headed toward
muscat
albuquerque burned and plundered the
city then cut off the ears and noses of
the survivors
the british were not far behind
[Music]
in the wake of world war ii empires
everywhere were disappearing the notion
of people of color being ruled by whites
from some distant land had become
illegitimate how did people here feel
about the british before they left there
was a feeling that kind of hatred but i
think
it was not you know a desire thing to
have you know somebody foreign
government uh
ruling your
own country and shaping your destiny and
the destiny of
your people in negotiating this new u.s
military commitment to the region we had
to take into account their sensibilities
these countries had only recently
achieved national independence
and they didn't want a large-scale us
military presence
the government of the united states has
created a new military command to help
ensure the security of a critically
important area of the world
the united states central command
it is responsible for implementing all
us military activity in the central
region
with its main headquarters located at
macdill air force base florida
it is vital to the united states
interest and our allies interest
that the unimpeded flow of oil out of
the persian gulf continues
we're going to put u.s forces in harm's
way and if the russians or any other
enemy a potential enemy wants to take on
the united states i'm going to give them
that opportunity to do that and i'm
going to give them with a sizable force
that can obviously cause them
quite a bit of damage
it is desirable from a political
viewpoint
in many of our host nations
that we not have a permanent military
presence
we have what we call an over the horizon
concept
in which
my forces and headquarters of course
would be invited in by a host nation
when that is accomplished
we will return to the continental united
states
on as expeditious manner as possible
implementation of u.s central command
required u.s military forces to remain
offshore over the horizon
the concept is entirely oriented toward
deterrence
it isn't designed as an occupation force
or an intervention force it is a
deterrent force
[Music]
your highness it is a pleasure for nancy
and me to welcome you to the united
states as a guest of the american people
so ronald reagan inherits the oil war
from jimmy carter at that point it's not
much of a war
it is a commitment to ensure that the
united states has access to the persian
gulf
it is no secret that the united states
has a vital national interest in the
middle east
we and our allies depend on oil
originating there much of it produced in
and nearby your country
yet we also recognize the value of
partnership
and respect for the culture and
aspirations of states like your own
so
[Music]
i'm standing on the border between
pakistan and afghanistan we were
smuggled into afghanistan by a young
mujahideen
the muslim word for freedom fighter or
fighter in a holy war
in this case as the mujahideen see it a
holy war against the soviets
a war they say that if they get weapons
from us or anyone else in the free world
they will win i'm sure he knows that in
vietnam we got our fingers burned indeed
we got our old hands burned when we
tried to help in this kind of situation
your hands were burned in vietnam but if
you don't agree to help us if you don't
ally yourself with us then all of you
your whole body will be burnt eventually
the carter administration saw the
soviet invasion of afghanistan as an
opportunity to trap the soviets into
something akin to
our vietnam war jimmy carter authorized
u.s assistance to the afghan mujahideen
when reagan became president he greatly
expanded that support
i'm from afghanistan and i got hurt by
the soviet bombing
they killed my mother and they killed my
family and they we almost lost 1 million
people to keep supporting that young
people you know we will after seven
years of war the world still wonders how
these afghan guerrilla fighters have
been able to force the soviet superpower
into a military stalemate
[Music]
hamid is a carpenter in eastern
afghanistan
he took his 15 year old son maragul out
of school four years ago
hamid like other parents in the village
takes his son to a local village teacher
where the lessons continue as they have
for generations
foreign
i am dedicating on behalf of the
american people
the march 22nd launch of the columbia
to
the people of afghanistan
in the context of the cold war the
afghanistan war contributed directly to
bringing about the fall of the soviet
union and the collapse of communism but
if you look at that same conflict in the
context of the oil war
it's not a great victory
it may not be a defeat
but it's the cause of more problems
afghanistan drew thousands of volunteers
like these from around the islamic world
bin laden left his comfortable life in
saudi arabia to become a leader of the
afghan arabs bin laden's victories
against the soviets were well publicized
in saudi arabia
now proclaiming the incursion of
bleeding wound gorbachev calls for the
withdrawal of over 100 000 soviet troops
in the end the afghan adventure is
considered a total failure for the
soviets and a tragedy for afghanistan
which retains its independence at the
cost of a million lives
[Music]
[Laughter]
you say that any
form of government that would be
acceptable to the afghan people would be
acceptable to the u.s
i would reiterate that our
hope is for the afghan people to have a
chance
to make their own choices concerning
their government
free from the occupation of foreign
troops it's my impression that it's very
islamic oriented
and you're saying you don't care what
kind of government it is as long as the
the
afghan people want this government yet
in nicaragua you insist on a democracy
i'm not sure that i said we don't care
what i tried to say was that it is not
up to us to determine
i thank you all for your interest in
your very very good and
well informed questions
[Music]
in 1980 when saddam hussein invaded iran
intending to take advantage of the
disarray caused by the iranian
revolution
u.s policymakers were not terribly
displeased
only when iranian forces turned the
table
on saddam
and posed a threat to his regime did the
united states take notice
the american response was then to
intervene
on behalf of saddam
here
[Music]
i want to speak directly afternoon in
the vital interests of the american
people
vital interests that are at stake in the
persian gulf area
it may be easy for some after a
near-record 54-month economic recovery
to
forget just how critical the persian
gulf is to our national security
but i think everyone in this room and
everyone hearing my voice now
can remember the woeful impact of the
middle east oil crisis of a few years
ago
the endless demoralizing gas lines the
shortages the rationing
the escalating energy prices
double-digit inflation
and the enormous dislocation that shook
our economy to its foundations the
united states was drawn into this war
because the reagan administration feared
that iran might prevail
and so we provided intelligence to
saddam hussein we facilitated saddam
hussein's acquisition of weapons
we provided so-called dual use
technologies helicopters for example
trucks computers at the state department
secretary of state george schultz and
iraq's foreign minister tariq aziz met
to discuss implementing a uncease fire
in the gulf years yes it is
at the beginning of winter
march and every
month
but not in july and august
amazingly in the middle of this effort
to support saddam hussein against the
ayatollahs
the reagan administration also undertook
a bizarre effort to provide weapons to
iranian forces in hopes of securing
iranian assistance in freeing a small
number of american hostages in lebanon
the so-called iran contra affair
by giving iran what it wanted military
arms the u.s was hoping to get what it
wanted the return of american hostages
in beirut
at this juncture of the iran-iraq war
the united states was supporting both
opposing sides
saddam hussein was unhappy and expressed
that unhappiness by ordering the stark
attack
the stark was hit by two exorcists the
first one went through it the second one
detonated and you had a horrendous
explosion saddam claimed that the attack
on the stark was an accident and
apologized and even offered some
compensation to the victims
u.s officials have accepted iraq's
explanation that that was an unintended
attack and a tragic accident
both iran and iraq depended upon oil
export and therefore iraq began
targeting iranian tankers in iran of
course attempted to do the same in
reverse our actual residential quarters
were downstairs
but this had then always been the dining
room for the family
when kuwait tankers began to be targeted
the emir of kuwait asked the united
states to protect his tanker fleet let
me re-emphasize for all of you that the
united states commitment the security of
kuwait and our other friends in the gulf
is stronger than ever
the waste resolve and the face of
iranian intimidation and terrorism is
most impressive
the result was that the kuwaiti tanker
fleet was re-flagged began to fly the
stars and stripes
it took about seven hours for three u.s
navy warships to escort those two
re-flagged kuwaiti tankers through the
area of greatest risk the strait of
hormuz marked this point well
the use of the vital sea lanes of the
persian gulf will not be dictated by the
iranians
weakness a lack of resolve and strength
will only encourage those who seek to
use the flow of oil as a tool
a weapon to cause the american people
hardship at home and promote conflict
and violence throughout the middle east
and the world
that's end of statement
there are some people worried these
ships are safe some people worry that
you're going to get in the shooting war
you're going to get in the shooting wars
guarantee the americans are you going to
get in the shooting middle east
in comparison with the united states
navy the iranian navy was quite small
but they did have the capability of
mining the persian gulf
we are outraged at the activities of the
iranians and dumping mines and
international waterways a mine is a
pretty indiscriminate weapon
it doesn't know what flag is being flown
on the fan tail of the ship that happens
to run into it
in the face of threats from iran
officials at the pentagon held their
breath soon after the navy began the
mission of escorting kuwaiti tankers a
u.s navy warship hit one of those mines
the incident provided a pretext for the
united states to escalate
those who made sound general quarters
general quarters eye general quarters
general quarters all hands man your
battle stations
when provoked and as a measured response
a carrier battle group with its ships
and planes destroyed iranian gun boats
and an oil drilling platform
[Music]
mr president could you do a u-turn and
go about 50 feet and try just one more
time and then we'll be done
to 75 then come on back hang out with
you while he doesn't
stop eating you're not supposed to eat
very good
[Music]
when iran iraq war finally ended it
found saddam hussein more or less broke
he owed kuwait billions of dollars that
iraq had borrowed basically said to the
kuwaitis
i was fighting iran on your behalf on
the behalf of all my era brothers and i
think the only decent thing for you to
do would be to write off this loan
kuwaiti said ain't going to do that and
that resulted in saddam hussein invading
kuwait when this administration began
we sought to uh
to strengthen the ceasefire between iran
and iraq
and to improve relations with iraq
saddam's calculation that he could get
away with invading and annexing kuwait
stemmed from his understanding of u.s
attitude toward iraq we were his friend
we were his de facto ally
i believe he thought he could just take
over kuwait and then there'd be a lot of
talk and discussion and he would be able
to turn kuwait a sovereign nation a
member of the arab league a member of
the united nations into province 19.
and in three days iraq had 120 000
troops
and 850 tanks in kuwait
moving south toward the saudi border
and it was this clear and rapidly
escalating threat
that led king fahd of saudi arabia to
ask for our assistance
now for the first time since the
creation of u.s central command the war
plan
successive commanders of centcom had
developed was put into operation
hi and welcome to air force now i'm tech
sergeant jim langdon beginning news in
blue this month military airlift has
been phenomenal in the deployment phase
of desert shield it has moved more
people and equipment faster and farther
than any other time in history the
stakes are high
iraq is already a rich and powerful
country
that possesses the world's second
largest reserves of oil
and over a million men under arms
it's the fourth largest military in the
world
our country
now imports nearly half the oil it
consumes
and could face a major threat to its
economic independence
he dares come across that border and
come down here i'm completely confident
that we're going to kick
iraq itself controls some 10
of the world's proven oil reserves
iraq plus kuwait
controls twice that i cannot predict
just how long it will take to convince
iraq to withdraw from
from kuwait
sanctions will take time to have their
full intended effect
we will continue to review all options
with our allies but let it be clear
we will not let this aggression stand
centcom's purpose had fundamentally
changed
at the outset the aim had been to
prevent the soviets from intruding into
this region of the world that americans
considered to be so vital now the
purpose was to prevent a hostile nation
within the region from coming to
dominate it
what at stake is more than one small
country it's a big idea new world order
you need to make sure you bracket that
so that
that becomes
yourself where diverse nations are drawn
together in common cause to achieve the
universal aspirations of mankind peace
and security freedom and the rule of law
such as a world worthy of our struggle
and worthy of our children
the community of nations is resolutely
gathered to condemn do you have a stop
well
i just want to be sure that there's no
confusion and everybody's happy with
worthy of our children i don't want
people to think it's worthy of our
children their lives in other words that
you're saying
that the root peace and security freedom
and the rule of law such as worthy of
our struggle
they know we must make sure the lions
share the world's oil resources don't
fall into his hands only to finance the
further aggressions of this tyrant
[Music]
back in august when you talked about
oil protecting one of these reserve they
talked about american jobs in fact the
american way of life are being
endangered yet when you're out on the
campaign trail you seem to shy away from
oil
you said demonstrators don't seem to
understand that we're not going to go to
war for oil but that was one of the
things you talked about and in fact
isn't oil part of the american national
interest isn't that a main reason we're
there it is a prominent but it is not
the main reason or i'd say a main reason
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states and mrs bush
accompanied by major general evan
haltman
what was and is at stake
is not simply our energy or
economic security
and the stability of a vital region
but the prospects for peace
in the post
cold war era
the promise of a new world order based
upon the rule of law this will not be
another vietnam
we ended up with a war undertaken in
order to evict the iraqi army from
kuwait but also undertaken with at least
the hope if not the expectation that
inflicting a military defeat on saddam
hussein would lead to his being
overthrown
this is a large
combined arms army
as tanks those personnel carriers it has
air defense guns our strategy to go
after this army is very very simple
first we're going to cut it off and then
we're going to kill it there's not going
to be panama or
rambo-like movie this is going to be a
bloody
long terrible walk
[Music]
today we're on a rate of processing over
a thousand prisoners a day
400 to 500 was a goal uh in the books
that was to be an ideal number or a max
number and we have uh over we have
more than doubled that and we're
extremely pleased about it
we've all been searched and they're now
in a holding tank area
that will handle approximately 50 to 100
prisoners
this is where the first processing lines
begin
at this point in time they're just set
up here
and they're ready to go through the
processing stages and steps that we'll
be uh taking at this time
i've just given you a tour of one of the
eight dining facilities the enclosure
iii has set up
and uh what it's like to feed three
thousand four thousand pws every day and
uh
[Music]
thanks thanks for coming to take the
tour
[Applause]
our armed forces fought with honor and
valor aggression is defeated kuwait is
free the war is over
kuwait is liberated
iraq's army is defeated
our military objectives are met
[Music]
in the wake of operation desert storm
president george herbert walker bush
lamented that there had been no clean
ending
he was right saddam hussein survived in
power
that united nations sanctions
must remain in place against iraq
until a new leadership emerges in
baghdad
a leadership willing to live in peace
with its neighbors and its own people
he crushed an uprising by iraqi shiites
and kurds with u.s forces standing by
[Music]
in this edition of air force news
our correspondents report on operations
in the arabian gulf because of iraq's
non-compliance with united nations
resolutions president bush committed u.s
troops to a coalition force monitoring
the 32nd parallel in southern iraq
as far as saudi arabia and kuwait were
concerned saddam still posed a proximate
threat to their survival
so the bush administration made the
fateful decision to maintain u.s forces
in the region on a permanent basis
[Music]
my fellow americans this evening i want
to speak with you about an attack by the
government of iraq
against the united states this past
april the kuwaiti government uncovered
what they suspected was a car bombing
plot
to assassinate former president george
bush while he was visiting kuwait city
the united states is conducting daily
combat air patrols
over northern and southern iraq
earlier today i ordered america's armed
forces to strike military and security
targets in iraq
with some frequency is targeting iraqi
military installations on the ground
nobody's paying attention
[Music]
the idea was to contain saddam and
therefore maintain regional order and
stability
the actual effect however was to inspire
terrorism directed at the united states
and intended to force the united states
to withdraw its forces entirely
we declared a jihad a holy war against
the united states government because it
is unjust criminal and tyrannical he
said i'm opposed to the presence of
foreign troops in saudi arabia for two
reasons
islamic reasons
and patriotic reasons because he said i
don't want my homeland to be occupied by
foreign troops
secondly islamic reasons because he said
there's makkah and medina
the holiest places for muslims
we don't want non-muslim troops nearby
bin laden and others
see their success in evicting the
soviets from afghanistan as indicative
of their ability to take on the other
superpower
to evict the other superpower
from the islamic world and that's us
the truck parked suspiciously close to
the perimeter explodes
the blast is heard more than 120 miles
away
i want to say a few words about
yesterday's outrageous attack on
americans in saudi arabia we will not
resist
we will not rest
in our efforts to find who is
responsible for this outrage
and heck
bin laden has declared war on the united
states of america
it's not like it's a secret
bill clinton's response to that is
ineffectual
as you know an explosion claimed the
lives of at least four sailors on one of
our naval vessels the uss cole this
morning
terrorism is one of the greatest dangers
we face in this new global era
today
we have struck back
the united states launched an attack
this morning
on one of the most active terrorist
bases in the world
it is located in afghanistan
and operated by groups affiliated with
osama bin laden
today i ordered our armed forces to
strike at terrorist-related facilities
in afghanistan and sudan
from a military perspective clinton is
an activist president
but from both a military and a political
point of view he's an activist president
who doesn't get things done
if you had an opportunity to give a
message to
president clinton what would that
message be
mentioning the name of clinton provokes
disgust and revulsion
the president has a heart that knows no
words a heart that kills hundreds of
children definitely knows no words
our people in arabia will send him
messages without words because he does
not understand words
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
9 11 happens this administration filled
with people who imagine that they are
great experts catches them utterly by
surprise
terrorism against our nation will not
stand
and now if you join me in a moment of
silence
and george w bush has the unenviable
task of explaining to the american
people what happened and why this
happened and how it's never going to
happen again
with every atrocity they hope that
america grows fearful
retreating from the world
and forsaking our friends
they hate our freedoms
our freedom of religion
our freedom of speech
our freedom to vote and assemble and
disagree with each other
and tonight the united states of america
makes the following demands
on the taliban
deliver to united states authorities all
the leaders of al qaeda who hide in your
land
in the wake of 9 11 the george w bush
administration made some demands on the
taliban then in power in
afghanistan not unreasonable demands
fork over the conspirators
and give us absolute guarantees that you
will not
provide sanctuary for
anti-american terrorists any time in the
future they refuse to comply
and now to the war against the taliban
it's been almost a week now since the
bombing campaign against afghanistan
began as you know it's not easy to get a
complete picture of what is happening we
were fortunate this week to have our
reporter dan harris on a trip organized
by the taliban to kandahar
we were always in the company of young
taliban soldiers good-natured and
well-armed they put us up in these guest
houses and fed us meals cooked by a chef
who had lost his arm fighting the
russians everyone from the man on the
street
to the top brass said no to handing over
bin laden we are not ready to head our
such a muslim
to
foreigners especially to americans who
are presently
killing our innocent people so it's
necessary for us to overthrow the
taliban wasn't necessary for us to then
stay in afghanistan going on the better
part of two decades
u.s officials still insist it's only a
matter of time before the taliban
collapses
they admit it's taking longer than they
thought
while the pentagon continues to release
videos of pinpoint strikes
administration officials admit they are
frustrated with progress in the war
and this interesting twist a former
soviet air base may be put in use again
as a staging ground for u.s military
operations in afghanistan
huge fireballs erupted today directly
over the torah borah caves hiding the
final remnants of the al-qaeda and
possibly their leader osama bin laden
along the way a usb 52 dropped its
payload in front of us in the direction
of tora bora then a two-mile hike to the
village of kamado here we saw more than
15 homes obliterated a guard dog guarded
nothing the air was thick with a stench
of death
why did the soviet empire the soviet
empire collapsed as a result of
overstretch
the soviets tried to do something that
they should not have done they tried to
pacify afghanistan
what appears to be the logic of bin
laden's war against the united states is
to elicit that same kind of reaction on
the part of the united states
the americans have forgotten history and
haven't learned from it says this
taliban soldier we will bury their
skulls in the mouth
the purpose of the 911 attack was not to
defeat the united states but to cause
the united states to behave stupidly in
ways that would ultimately lead to
the defeat of the united states and once
the united states accepted defeat
withdrawal from the islamic world
clearing the path
for bin laden then to move on to his
second objective of purifying islam
itself
that strategic logic actually worked we
were drawn into an unnecessary and
unwinnable war in the heart of kabul u.s
marines reclaim a strip of america the
u.s embassy closed since 1989 will
reopen soon a new era in u.s afghan
relations but these marines are tense
bullets zing overhead at night this is
where the marines will patrol next the
streets of kandahar the spiritual home
of the taliban
now even as u.s forces prepare to enter
the airport in kandahar pentagon
officials emphasizing tonight that they
will not stay long as an occupying force
inside of afghanistan in four short
months
our nation destroyed afghanistan's
terrorist training camps and free the
country from brutal oppression
[Applause]
kabul is a city on edge an explosive mix
of 2 million people mostly refugees
hundreds of thousands of weapons and no
government we are winning the war on
terror
this is an instance of the american
insistence
that we have achieved significant
results
when in fact we haven't
[Music]
will the us be as successful in war
against iraq as it was in afghanistan 66
say yes 26 say no so the public thinks
that the u.s can get the job done if
president bush gives the order in fact i
think you had a paul wolf last week that
showed that 78 of the american people
think we should go after iraq next so i
think that the president's got an
opportunity to lead here i think with
the right leadership and the right
strategy we can accomplish a lot there
bush and those around him particularly
vice president cheney secretary of
defense rumsfeld deputy secretary of
defense wolfowitz they didn't see saddam
hussein's iraq as a threat or a danger
they saw it as an opportunity we'll have
to deal with the networks
one of the ways to do that is to drain
the swamp they live in
and that means dealing not only with the
terrorists but those who harbor
terrorists they believed fancifully
transforming iraq into some semblance of
a pro-western liberal democracy
was going to be easy
and they believed that by achieving that
in iraq they would then lay the basis
for a broader transformation
they try to market the iraq war by
portraying saddam hussein as the
embodiment of evil as somebody who is
acquiring weapons of mass destruction
and if given the chance will pass the
weapons of mass destruction to al-qaeda
we know now that's all bogus
saddam hussein had nothing to do with
911. he certainly didn't have weapons of
mass destruction and indeed didn't even
have a significant weapons of mass
destruction program underway
uh roger they can continue with that
task uh out to you
uh bravo one this is bravo over
uh a human life is a human life a human
limits a human if you care about your
human life then
you have to lift the embargo
well no
that's not for me because i'm really an
engineer looking at the super gun and i
am engineer too and this is the easiest
way for us
[Applause]
what we're giving you are facts and
conclusions based on solid intelligence
this is evidence not conjecture this is
true this is all well documented now i
believe the facts that have brought us
to this fateful vote are not in doubt
that if left unchecked
saddam hussein will continue to increase
his capacity to wage biological and
chemical warfare
and will keep trying to develop nuclear
weapons
we're back with operation iraq freedom
the war against saddam hussein is
underway the white house announced
tonight at about 9 45 that the president
would be coming out to say
that the process of disarming iraq is
underway american and coalition forces
are in the early stages of military
operations to disarm iraq to free its
people
and to defend the world from grave
danger
right in front of us
at least 10 major buildings destroy tom
in the course of about two minutes an
amazing sight
just like out of an action movie but
this is real this is real this is shock
and war tom
the less than any 40 cruise missiles
have come in at this point
one building after another going down
tom they they're
taking out whole buildings with these
with these cruise missiles
whole buildings
saddam hussein has constructed
the west bank of the city in the past 20
years of his government it's
disappearing before our very eyes
the conviction was
that a demonstration of american
military supremacy not simply american
military strength
american military supremacy the capacity
to win decisive
victory
quickly and cheaply and the will to do
that
that in a sense that would transform the
entire landscape in the region
and let's face it if you look at the
first six weeks of the war
they thought they had it done
the iraq war had ended
on to the next thing
foreign
they're trying to take over the
government we're not going to let them
you know we i am the government i am the
governor of this place by default and by
the law of war
we conquered these people so now i'm
responsible for taking care of them
i will take any questions if anyone has
any if i don't know the answer i'll make
one up we want to freedom
freedom
not just from saddam we want to freedom
also from america
okay
in april 2003 the 82nd airborne had
commandeered a schoolhouse in fallujah
to be used as billets for an infantry
company yet as long as gis remained in
the schoolhouse there could be no
classes angry iraqis gathered to protest
the presence of the americans they threw
stones
they chanted anti-american slogans and
eventually somebody no one really knows
who fired a shot
consequence the americans launched a
fuselade of fire that killed more than a
dozen iraqis and wounded dozens more
american casualties were zero it was
like the boston massacre of 1770
except now the americans were the
redcoats and the iraqis were the
patriots demanding that foreign troops
leave their city
i don't lose on the british army
the british
are good
if you are an iraqi it's difficult to
buy the rhetoric of we're here to spread
freedom
anglo
english british those terms stand for
something other than liberation they
stand for oppression they stand for
manipulation they stand for exploitation
the locals they didn't like them working
with americans
and pretty much nightly they would shoot
at the bunker fire rockets fire mortars
things of that nature but it was it was
an adjustment quite exciting getting
used to the nightly gunfire and the
fireworks shows
so things are better now
things are much better uh since the
transfer of authority i think that uh at
least in my perception and walking the
streets is the people
uh come to terms with the fact that you
know we are not here to take over their
country we're here to you know help out
where we can welcome
your source for the latest news on
operation iraqi freedom with the help of
coalition advisors iraqi security forces
captured seven insurgents involved in
extrajudicial killing cells during two
raids in the capital city iraqi forces
detained two insurgents believed to be
involved and several kidnappings of
iraqi citizens working for coalition
forces some of the others arrested are
suspected of weapons dealing and backing
foreign
the first cohort of u.s commanders
charged with the occupation of iraq put
down a very big bet
they wagered that repression would
produce submission
[Applause]
name uh
lieutenant charles wilkins where are you
from columbus ohio kind of give me an
idea what we just got we just got
finished here what we just finished here
was the uh
earthwork the horizontal work for a 2
000 man
fundamentally a holding facility uh we
understand there's going to be uh some
activity whereby we may have some
detainees we need a place to hold them
concertina wire triple strand to
military standard to uh i guess kind of
keep the detainees in
what's it for
holding uh from when i hear hold into
whoever we take tonight
prisoner and whoever
whoever's alive i guess i don't know
the americans locked up thousands
often on specious grounds but the
prisons in which they were confined
proved to be a breeding ground for
insurgents
a policy of round them up
and lock them up only made things worse
that's me
and that's me too in the front they told
us to take off our clothing and we said
no saying it's against islam
then
they started beating us
american politicians and u.s commanders
speaking with one voice depicted our
purposes as benign and enlightened
and we intended to make iraq a better
place for iraqis
the photos at abu ghraib simply
exposed that as a lie in the new era
that is coming to iraq your country will
no longer be held captive to the will of
a cruel dictator when american leaders
embark upon some expansionist project
they rarely speak plainly about its true
purpose instead they talk about
america's mission to
spread freedom and democracy it's a way
of camouflaging imperialism and making
it more palatable to the american people
the purpose of u.s military involvement
in and around the persian gulf has never
been about freedom
it's been about oil and dominion
the nightmare that saddam hussein has
brought to your nation will soon be over
you are a good and gifted people
the heirs of a great civilization that
contributes to all humanity
you deserve better than tyranny and
corruption and torture chambers
you deserve to live as free people
and i assure every citizen of iraq
your nation will soon be free
[Music]
it's pretty amazing to go out there and
the kids just gather around
any soldier like crazy and that's i mean
ask for candy and
that's the ass for money
uh
and pins and pencils i mean anything i
mean they're just eager for
anything that your soldiers can surely
just love it
you know and that's how
we're going to win this thing eventually
is
you know the adults are have already
made up their minds and you know most
which way they're going to go but the
kids
in a generation are going to understand
that we weren't here to do anything but
help them and they're the ones that are
going to understand democracy
down the road
[Music]
on november 8th operation alpha year
kicked off at the request of iraq's
prime minister ihad alawi and the
interior of iraqi government the marine
corps regimental combat team 1 and 7
along with elements of the u.s army were
called upon to assault and clear the
corrupted city of fallujah which had
been acting as a staple for numerous
anti-iraqi insurgents and various
foreign fighters over the past several
months
general there's a lot of debate back in
the states as you know as to who exactly
we're fighting in the streets down there
are we fighting remnants of the saddam
regime are we fighting
terrorists coming in from outside
jihadists or are we fighting just iraqis
so we're ticked off at the occupation
the fighters in a job didn't have the
will to fight that
the the fighters that we're seeing here
do
i don't know whether that's because
they're a different
a different
political group or
a different tribe it might have to do
with the
you know this is supposedly the last
stronghold of
the
insurgency here in iraq
so it might be you know kind of backed
into a corner thing
car bombs have targeted hundreds of
innocent iraqis including dozens of
sunni arabs leaving a mosque in al-anbar
province
suicide vest bombers killed over three
dozen students at mustanzerea university
in baghdad
14 iraqi policemen were killed execution
style while bound and blindfolded last
week
the iraqi vice president was wounded by
an assassination attempt
though thankfully and impressively he
remains undaunted and is already back on
the job
sometimes the attacks against us
either seem to be
ignored or assisted by iraqi security
forces i'm wondering what actions are
being taken against
people that we might deem
to be corrupt or counter to our efforts
you know that in every
conflict in our country's history there
have been those who said let's toss in
the towel
it isn't working they say
it was true in the revolutionary war
george washington was almost fired
it would be interesting i think to see
what the
true historians will say of this period
20 or 30 years from now
for a parent the thought of burying a
son or daughter is unimaginable last
week the unimaginable became a reality
in walpole it was a day that brought
townspeople together in support and
grief
outside the church nancy and andrew
basefit senior watched the flag-draped
casket of their only son slip into a
hearse for the short ride to a nearby
cemetery
when my son was serving
i was immensely proud
of of his decision to serve and i was
immensely proud
of everything that that he did
i actually felt it was my responsibility
to my son
uh to to to speak the truth as i
as i was given to understand the truth
so you're a conservative but you're an
obama man
i i've said that in print the prospect
of an obama presidency i think is the
one where there is
some hope of rethinking the emphasis
placed on military power
[Applause]
he has kept his promise
to responsibly bring you home from iraq
obama
ran in 2008
making two promises
one promise was elect me president and i
will bring the iraq war to a responsible
end
because of you
and the work
of those of you in uniform have done
we are now able to end this war
the second was elect me president and i
will win the afghanistan war
which he described as the necessary war
it is in our vital national interest to
send an additional 30 000 u.s troops to
afghanistan
let me impress you on that andy if we
withdraw you will have a country that
has
allows al-qaeda and its ilk to operate
to train to have bases why is that not a
threat it seems to me that we should at
least examine the possibility
that there are ways to prevent that from
happening that don't require us to
maintain tens of thousands of us troops
there in perpetuity
[Music]
coalition forces launched operation
odyssey dawn to establish a no-fly zone
over libya march 19th
meanwhile yesterday marked the
definitive end of the gaddafi regime in
libya
and there too our military played a
critical role in shaping
a
situation on the ground in which the
libyan people can build their own future
at least 3 000 people died last year
trying to reach europe by crossing the
mediterranean flimsy vessels provided by
people smugglers proving no match for
the high seas i've made it clear that i
will never hesitate to use our military
swiftly decisively and unilaterally when
necessary
that's why we're going after al qaeda
wherever they seek a foothold
[Applause]
obama says we're going to abandon the
methods that have not worked not to
rethink basic policy
but to embrace a different set of
methods to continue the war
rather than invading and occupying
countries we're going to place a greater
emphasis on air strikes missile firing
drones
and therefore the american people
once more disengaged
iraq seems to be disintegrating as
terrorist organization iss now controls
mosul iraq's second largest city
fallujah in much of ramadi
parts of
baja
de grete
though significantly outnumbered isis
managed to overwhelm
overwhelm entire divisions of the iraqi
army many of whom removed their uniforms
and ran
when we elected president obama i think
the expectations uh were that he was
going to you know score an a remember
he's the guy that upon inaugur being
inaugurated received the nobel peace
prize he doesn't deserve an a he
probably deserves about a c why does
this matter why should people care about
what's happening in iraq given the
problems we have here at home these are
vital vital u.s interests in iraq number
one the counterterrorism the al-qaeda
threat number two just the supply of
energy resources to global markets
iraq through 2035 will will account for
45 of all of the growth in oil energy
exports if iraq were to collapse in a
major civil war and sectarian war um the
the effects to our own economy here at
home
would be would be quite serious
good afternoon everybody please be
seated
it is a great honor
to return
to
the national defense university
[Music]
we're addressing that man
in early 2015 i received an email
inviting me to have lunch with the
president in the oval office
and first i thought it was a joke
it turned out not to be a joke
i reported to the oval office
and we had lunch one on one
he clearly had either read my books
or had been
briefed on my books
i had gone in with a list of things i
wanted to suggest to him
i suggested a serious evaluation
of
the origins of our wars and their
conduct
[Music]
i know i talked to him about the
all-volunteer force
i mean why are the american people
detached
from our wars
i mean there is a very simple answer
it's because unless you volunteer to
sign up
you your family you are untouched by
these wars
on each of the points i made
his basic response was
that's a really good idea
now let me explain to you why i can't do
that
and i came away thinking that even
when a president like obama tries to
reach outside the bubble
and hear of their voices
even if that's undertaken
seriously
uh that is unlikely to have any real
effect
because after an hour in the oval office
i left
and
this
staff is still there
congress is still there
the new york times and the washington
post and nbc news are still
there
and they create the operating
environment which constrains a president
and during my administration
i we all together destroyed the
caliphate
and now we want
the countries in the region
to police their own borders we don't
want to be a
policeman in this case
but we're keeping the oil remember that
i've always said that keep the oil
the folly has now been laid bare
the news of the day is one more
president campaigning to bring the
troops home only to continue the war
once in office
and this time without even the pretext
of a coherent strategy
we took action last night to stop
a war
we did not
take action to start a war
this is a war we've been fighting for 40
years a war we fight because we believe
our way of life depends on access to oil
against local people
who don't want us
to dominate their politics
when people say to me thank you for your
service i just ignore it i find it
annoying but more to the point it's
pretty clear within the ranks of the
active duty
military that phrase is a red flag
if i say to a soldier thank you for your
service
i'm making myself feel good
i'm making a pretense
of fulfilling some sort of
obligation or responsibility
and having thanked you for your service
i have now acquitted that responsibility
and i can therefore go about my business
feeling virtuous
[Music]
the citizens we have a responsibility to
be seriously concerned about the
well-being of our soldiers and that
serious concern simply doesn't exist in
our country
what we have is gestures
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you